everybody is a stakeholder in science
whether people realize it or not science
outreach is an opportunity for
scientists and researchers to learn as
much as is an opportunity for
communities to learn and I think it's
about building a mutual appreciation for
the role that science can play in our
lives
science outreach is important because it
humanizes science and scientist it helps
scientists remember that they are people
and that they should be able to connect
with other types of people to talk about
science biggest challenge for science
outreach as a scientist is that we had
to learn from scratch how to present
ourselves how to explain what we do you
have to really be a jack-of-all-trades
which is sometimes really challenging
when you've got a lot on your plate it
has to be fun that's my goal is for
everyone to walk away with a smile on
their face I think if people are
passionate and are investing into
something that they think is worthwhile
doing it's gonna help everyone Indian we
can feel really siloed sometimes when
we're all out doing our different ways
of outreach so to get everyone in the
same room and just say what are you
doing how are you doing and how are the
communities responding to what you're
doing
feels really thoughtful and that's why
we're here at SIA 18 the way that it's
been facilitated so far has been
incredible also in looking at the
program kind of felt like I had a say in
it this idea of the unconference and not
setting the agenda until you know what
the participants want then developing
the agenda from that and then still
letting the agenda and the the topics
evolve once the people are actually
there in the room and talking to one
another I feel like the key to it is
intermingling industries and an interest
seat has encouraged us to do exchange
more I don't think I've met a more kind
of articulate and engaged bunch of
people tons of very in-depth
conversation about things that we're
very very
this conference is like these are the
things I'm working on can we all kind of
talk together and try to work this out a
big challenge that sigh out is already
touching on is this idea of how do you
measure impact around science outreach
programs and that's something that I
really want to do better to understand
am i serving the people that I've I'm
patting myself on the back for serving
we're having conversations or having
dialogues we're having debates about
public engagement with science and what
that means for us on a personal level an
institutional level so it's a rare
opportunity to meet people that actually
have professionally science
communicators and when science outreach
learn about their different perspectives
their work share and compare notes
successes failures and concerns we've
been able to really hear about
opportunities and programs and ideas and
models that can be duplicated on other
institutions
we're kind of still building the
community around science outreach and on
one hand that's very powerful because we
can very intentionally build a community
but on the other hand it can be very
daunting because it's a lot of
infrastructure to set up and so it's
nice to come to a conference like this
come with people from all over the
country that are doing outreach science
outreach professionally and learn some
of the best practices develop the
network of professionals it's been
really really fun
[Music]